[Music]
it's real
[Music]
[Music]
calling jacksepticeye
you son of a beast
you thought you could escape the
challenge
no no okay all right i'm excited for
this year we're changing the game to
stay relevant what's relevant these days
squid game come waking
no more water bottles
this time we're doing the what's it
called
that's right i like how we're doing this
when squid game is there no one cares
i just want to do it it looks fun yeah
we're gonna make our own i've never made
one okay good and you know the loser
it's bad
here we go i got ourselves a little
arts and crafts here you go jack
pick your favorite color maybe this one
i was gonna go with pink because it's
nice-looking
i'll be green okay all right i'll go
pink then green's best just despite you
okay oh they're so tiny yeah not the
children but well oh swedish uh jackie
i just realized i have no speakers so
we're just gonna have to follow up with
the looking okay that's easy just
imagine that they're doing something
cool i don't know what color goes with
green and colorblind are you calling
right slightly yeah oh okay okay halfway
okay i'll eyeball it i guess is this a
talent that people are supposed to have
that you're supposed to just know we're
halfway sooner you just fold it in the
middle first and then that's how you
knew who you at okay never mind
okay beautiful now he'll tell us that
you're not supposed to actually flatten
this edge or something
okay
okay
kill an egg
okay i'm gonna fold that over okay
oh no mine is not symmetric i've already
failed what is this okay i thought mine
was bad mine was like a little bit off i
thought you were gonna say the same
thing it's so bad
it's half
okay
no no we need to learn are you learning
yeah okay so now you get green paper
see if you can get it right on your
second attempt i thought for sure you
would be bad at arts and crafts why i
don't know i'm very talented i was i'm
not saying say it i didn't think you
would be i don't know i thought you knew
about potatoes and fair enough all i do
is yell at things too compensate okay
cool when we fold two then nice
perfectly symmetrical both of them
killing it
okay
now one
just draw the rest of the owl just put
pull it out you grab one of them fold it
over okay you just make a corner they
don't do it all the way i think i did
this one better than you
damn it
same thing let me guess okay oh the
other one
okay yeah i don't assume
nice
they're way ahead of us okay wait wait
just in
yeah i think just in oh say no let's go
let's go let's go let's go hi
hype in the chat him in the chat is
everyone at home losing their minds
right now scythe better be adding like
epic now yeah oh
cyrus is hyping he's vibing so hard to
this okay
[Music]
let's go
and then you interlock them
excuse me i missed i looked away two
seconds oh too late no too late you
can't go back you lose point to me point
to me
just put them like that on top of each
other just like that yep oh
we are killing it right now
there it is oh
really sticking it to the gamer
stereotype
oh god
okay
easy it's like a woven i think i'm
having issues though now what
oh it goes in
oh it's like putting together a
cardboard box
we're actual children okay
can we do another one sure i feel like
they have many of them
already
okay this one's good
all right so we got
let's go
pretty cool yeah yeah let's go let's
just keep doing this all videos i love
it next time we're going to fold origami
yeah then we're going to make our own
candles and then we're going to learn
how to pick logs become lock picking
lawyer i mean today
now the real challenge begins no more
fun and baby games real games gang
first of all i've won all the other
years oh yeah right side dude
did a replay yes
this is the year i'm gonna beat you okay
okay i'll let you start because okay
i'll set up my swedish thunder edgar
will be a random distraction in this
game let's add some indians a lot indian
life yeah that looks cool right actually
that's cool that looks sick
all right let's go
let's go come on i gotta hide for you i
kind of want you to do it all right
listen
damn it no no file file what okay all
right okay get out of here let's get out
of here
this is so important all right
ego ego
channel it channel it is it left foot or
right click left foot if you're you're
right-handed there you go see the thing
is if you want it to flip you got to do
maximum power
we're so bad we're not even gonna hit it
yeah
oh i hit it first hit it's the first hit
of the evening that's just going to be
how the scores are covered whoever it
hits
okay leave it like that whoever lies
really
oh
he's getting close i don't like that
that's physically impossible
that was a that was
maybe i'll try a new technique
hidden in the corners
jesus christ see this technique they
call this two finger oh
[Music]
oh that was terrible don't patronize me
you hit it that's true i did hit it all
right do it again then
[Music]
it's this stupid one
god thanks challenge god i'm so talented
nice i can't go into depth
i can't do this
i won't survive it girl can i able to
feed you man come on throw it throw it
start down there you go
here we go
[Applause]
all right i've got warmed up now he's
got the technique
yes
let's go mr lachlan
ah
that's going to leave a mock tomorrow
it's going to look like a star
this room is very tiny
four two four two no no
okay
four two four
this is a two
[Music]
i'm missing okay go back okay distract
when he's doing it
go away
go
i don't care
it's gonna be game over soon
oh he's honestly gonna change
[Music]
do it
[Laughter]
you win this round jack i've run every
round but
next year i will defeat i'm the
three-time reigning champion somebody
better make me a trophy